[Musik]
im nordrhein-westfälischen eslohe wurde
über den esselbach diese fußgängerbrücke
gebaut ein brandneues stück aus eisen
und stahl vor ort sorgt das schöne
bauwerk allerdings für reichlich
kopfschütteln
denn direkt daneben gibt es schon einen
überweg diese brücke neben der brücke
finden viele bürger völlig überflüssig
ich persönlich für das absoluter
schwachsinn weil es bringt ja eigentlich
gar nichts weil es ist einfach nur geld
aus dem fenster werfen ich bin dem weg
noch nie gelaufen
ich glaube ich werde ihn auch nicht
laufen daher ist es einfach nur du musst
zur blödsinn
die dritte kann man doch weitergeben ich
weiß nicht warum so was gemacht wird
nach intensiven diskussionen und
planungen beschließt der gemeinderat die
ortsmitte umzugestalten wege werden
saniert das flusstal renaturiert und die
ufer neu gestaltet ein teil des konzepts
diese neue fußgängerbrücke für satte
95.000 euro
aber warum baut man eine fußgängerbrücke
wenn es direkt daneben schon eine gibt
zeitersparnis kann es wohl nicht sein
die überquerung dauert gleich lang
rausgeschmissenes geld
aber das geld was da es muss ja weg oder
reese das was ist aus dem fördertopf
irgendwie und deshalb die paar meter
hier nicht die hätte man immer laufen
können 95.000 das hätte man besser
anlegen können trotzdem ist man im
rathaus von der neuen brücke felsenfest
überzeugt sie schaffe mitten im ortskern
neue verbindungen in richtung
einkaufszentrum wir sind schon der
meinung dass es keine fehlplanung ist
alleine vor dem ziel das wir haben die
anbindung fußläufig eben nicht mit pkw
mit fahrzeugen sondern fußläufig von dem
vorhandenen essl markt von dem fachmarkt
an die bestehen der hauptstraße zu
gewährleisten
aha eine verbindung zwischen den beiden
einkaufszentren
aber die gibt es doch schon seit jahren
die neue brücke bringt da keinerlei
verbesserung durch konnte ihre
gebrauchten nicht ich für dummes zeug
auf wort gesagt alles andere schön
geworden hier hatten sie noch geld übrig
was macht man dann damit man baut was
was gar nicht so wichtig wer die eslohe
haben hier also künftig die qual der
wahl und können sich überlegen ob sie
links über die neue brücke gehen oder
rechts herum wie all die jahre zuvor